- [Mark] Launa, Launa,
Launa, where are you from originally?
- Pennsylvania.
- [Mark] Pennsylvania,
and how long have you been
down here in Skid Row?
- [Launa] About five years.
- [Mark] Five years,
and where do you stay, where do you sleep?
- [Launa] On Crocker.
- [Mark] Do you have a tent?
- I normally have a tent with my husband,
however right now I don't.
- [Mark] Where's your husband?
- He's in jail.
- [Mark] He's in jail,
what is he in jail for?
- Possession.
- [Mark] Possession.
How much time do you get for possession?
- Normally you don't get that much time,
however I think that they may
be trying to go hard on him
because he's had a couple of cases before.
So normally, you could
get out the same day
or a couple of days later,
but they're holding him 'til November.
- [Mark] What drug are
you using currently?
- [Launa] Heroin.
- [Mark] Heroin, and
do you do meth as well?
- [Launa] Oh, we mix it together.
- [Mark] You mix it together,
do you smoke it?
- [Launa] Shoot it.
- [Mark] Shoot it, okay.
What age did you start using drugs?
- [Launa] I didn't actually, well,
growing up, let's see,
around age 13 I smoked some weed,
from 13 to 20-something,
then I quit using drugs all together.
And then, I got real heavy
into cocaine for a while,
sniffing it,
quit, no problems,
then I got into crack,
and I did that for a good, a while,
and then I stopped doing the
crack and got into heroin,
crystal meth.
- [Mark] How much do you spend on,
what does your addiction cost?
Heroin and meth, per week, let's say.
- [Launa] I'd say probably
at least $100 and something a day.
So you go $150 times
seven or $160 times seven.
- [Mark] Yeah, so $150 a day.
- [Launa] Yeah, $160.
- [Mark] What do you guys do for money?
- Well, I get a VA pension,
and also my husband gets
social security, so.
However, I quit drinking (laughs).
- [Mark] It got you to stop drinking.
- Yeah, I just chose
hard drugs instead, yay.
- [Mark] And what's
going on with your arms?
You've got bandages on both arms.
- Yeah, these are from,
I'm not sure what they're from.
They said that they were
from shooting heroin
and my arms got infected.
They're doing a lot better,
but I don't think that's the case.
I don't know what the deal is,
they're really big holes.
Yeah, they go pretty deep.
- [Mark] How long have
you guys been married?
- Well, we've been together since,
well, we're not technically
married legally,
however I mean (indistinct) probably.
- [Mark] And are you ever on the street
taking guys for money?
- No.
- [Mark] You don't do that?
- No, I don't do that.
- [Mark] And do you have children?
- I have children.
- [Mark] Where are they?
- They're in Pennsylvania.
- [Mark] Who's raising your kids?
- Their dad.
I heard that my one son
got into a car crash,
my oldest son,
and ended up passing away.
I don't know if that's true or not
because I haven't talked to them in years.
I'm too afraid to call and find out.
- [Mark] How old would be your kids?
- They would be, let's see,
22 and
like 19,
22, 19.
- [Mark] Boy or girl?
- Two boys.
- [Mark] Two boys.
Tell me about your childhood.
- My childhood was great.
I'm an only child,
I don't have any brothers or sisters,
mom, dad, grandma, aunt, uncle.
My childhood was absolutely wonderful.
I didn't go without,
I didn't get beat.
- [Mark] Do you have both parents?
- No, I didn't.
I pretty much was raised by my grandma,
my mom worked all the time.
But my childhood was wonderful.
- [Mark] And no addiction,
no alcoholism, anything like that?
- Well, my mom and my dad were alcoholics.
- [Mark] They were?
- However, they still maintained a job.
We still had everything we needed,
got up and went to work everyday.
I mean, yeah, they drank and
got messed up or whatever,
they'd get, but, I mean,
my mom would wake up in the morning
and crack a beer as soon as she woke up.
- [Mark] Oh, really.
- Mm-hmm, but I'll tell you what,
she would drink all day and night,
the house would be clean,
we would have breakfast, lunch, dinner.
You couldn't even really
tell if you asked me.
- [Mark] And you were
drinking at one point?
- I didn't get into drinking
until I was in high school,
I started drinking.
And that got kinda,
I got carried away with that,
and I drank a whole lot, too much.
- [Mark] And then you
transitioned to harder drugs.
- Yeah, I quit for a while
and I didn't do anything,
I didn't do drugs or drink,
I was completely sober.
I went on that, what
do you call, Antabuse.
I was on Antabuse for three years.
And so, for three years,
I didn't get high,
I didn't drink, nothing.
I didn't like it,
but I did it.
It all went well,
and then I just decided
to start doing it again
because I was just,
everything was just so dull.
Really, it was,
I needed something to just change the pace
or do something different.
And I was bored and I
needed a new feeling,
I would wake up with the
same feeling everyday,
same stuff everyday.
And it just, fuck it,
I'm just gonna start drinking again.
So I did.
Then, when I came to California,
when I, yeah,
when I went to California, wherever,
I went to go to school
to be a dog trainer,
certified dog trainer.
I did that,
I didn't really go too far with that.
I haven't done it yet, actually,
I didn't finish the school
because I injured my back,
and that's how I met my husband.
And my husband had invited me over
to have a few beers,
and I never left (laughs).
We've been together ever since, so.
- [Mark] Do you ever talk to your family?
- I don't have any family,
they're all dead.
- [Mark] Your parents are gone?
- Yeah, my mom, my dad,
my gran, my aunts, my uncles.
- [Mark] Just you and your sons?
- And I think one of my
children are deceased.
I think, I'm not sure.
- [Mark] You don't feel
like reaching out to them?
- I'm kind of frightened to do so
because I mean,
I first of all,
how difficult would that be?
My first-born child passed away,
I knew nothing of it,
I was out doing drugs, drinking, partying,
and I never even knew anything about it.
Yeah, I'm not ready to
handle that yet, no.
So I haven't called to find out.
I apologize, I mean, I know
that's an awful thing to say,
but I'm not ready to,
there's nothing I could say.
So I can't,
I mean, I could,
but I haven't.
And I don't know if I will.
- [Mark] In the next five years,
where would you like to be?
Do you have any plans?
- I don't know.
I don't know.
And then my other son,
even if I did reach out to him,
what am I gonna say?
Hey, how you doing?
I fucked up,
I'm still fucking up,
I'm on the streets.
I can't, I can't do that.
I mean, I could, but I don't think,
that's not, this isn't
what I want them to see me.
No, last time they saw me,
I went into the military,
I was strong,
and now look.
I can't, I can't do that.